he may have married into one of the most
traditional institutions
in the world but prince philip could
never be accused of staying stuck in the
past
always one step behind his wife perhaps
but also
at the forefront of changes to the world
in which we live
the queen returns wearing the imperial
state crown her robes and train
royal biographers say that it was he who
insisted the queen's coronation
be shown to the world fighting back
against concerns that by
allowing the public to see live coverage
the mystique of royal life might somehow
be ruined
[Music]
he broke down the barriers between the
palace and the public
introducing the first royal walkabout in
1970
on the couple's tour of australia and
new zealand a tradition
enthusiastically embraced by politicians
presidents
and hollywood stars
but it was his role as an environmental
pioneer that is perhaps
his lasting legacy when he became the
first uk
president of the worldwide fund for
nature he shone an early light
on an issue that many in the world had
been slow to accept
all the statistics suggest that that we
are
at the moment using the natural capital
in this in a manner which is
unsustainable
far from media shy the prince was ahead
of his time
in understanding the power it could play
what do you want to see me about
this short film he starred in in 1951
unlike anything the royals had done
before and raising tens of thousands of
pounds
for the national playing fields
association for which he was a tireless
patron
we cannot possibly have enough people
helping us in this job
officially unofficially or indeed in any
capacity
it was absolutely vital and pivotal i
think to the success of the organization
then
that has enabled us to carry on
delivering the work to protect
parks and playing fields today the duke
of edinburgh was passionate
about ensuring that everybody and most
especially young people
had access to opportunities
[Music]
and while charity singles might now be
regulars on the charts
it was the duke that first came up with
the idea collaborating with his friend
frank sinatra to again benefit his
charity work
in buying this record you have joined
frank sinatra ivan novello
in helping to provide money for more
playing field
[Music]
being a modern royal is normally
associated with younger members of the
family
but in prince philip it is clear where
the next generation
have gained their inspiration
[Music]
fleeting